in honor of to tell the truth we wanted
to see if you would tell us um the truth
um or not in this round of final five
will you do that with us i'm with it all
right
[Applause]
it's my favorite game on the show okay
i'm gonna read off five statements about
you
and um you're going to let us know if
it's true or false and our studio
audience can get involved by giving a
thumbs up if they think it's true and a
thumbs down if you think it's false all
right you once ordered a jacuzzi on your
mom's credit card without asking her
thumbs up or thumbs down
i got a lot of thumbs up in the room
the answer is no oh
i ordered a baby grand piano at 11.
not a jacuzzi
11 at 11. and then what happened oh i
got my beat yeah i have a feeling that
thing was good
um okay you were a delivery mascot is
that true or false
i like every oh i'd say a thumbs down
over there a couple thumbs down
delivery mascot for a gourmet dessert
delivery company while i was a freshman
sophomore at howard university my
character's name was captain cravings
i got it i got to tell you this i know
everyone we might be short on time my
outfit were black dance tights sparkle
chuck all stars a black a silver long
ranger mask silver gloves
and a pink cape that said if you ever
need to be saved i'll 797 craze
and a white sweatshirt i wasn't topless
sometime i had a white sweatshirt and
i'd say captain cravings i want to see a
picture of that do you have any pictures
oh no thank god i don't well i have it
in my mind okay um you drink a gallon of
milk every day
y'all know black people
are lactose intolerant you know that's
you know that's false
i drink a gallon of water a day um okay
you own three to four hundred pairs of
shoes true or false
you guys saw black issues true
i got one hell of a shoe closet you're a
sneaker head right i'm a sneaker head
okay you won um 250 000 on who wants to
be a millionaire true or false
a lot of falses interesting oh brother
you don't think i could win a quarter of
a million dollars on who wants to be a
millionaire i was riding with you on all
of those questions that you know the
answers you were giving me
the answer is true i want a quarter
million dollars
for alzheimer's
that's like one of my favorite games who
wants to be a millionaire
congratulations on that
so as a last question i just want to say
um and ask how does it feel to
send off with a chef's kiss if you will
um
the beautiful show blackish which was
just one of its kind
so
revered
thank you so accoladed how do you feel
about
i feel i feel great with what we were
about what what what we were able to
accomplish over eight seasons uh
subject matters racism colorism sexism
postpartum depression politics
all of those things uh and edutain uh
people with that and thank all of you
guys and thank everyone at home for
watching thank you
anthony anderson for more information
about his campaign go get real about
diabetes.com
you can find it on our website at there
or on his website
[Music]